today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i put the link right below
this video
so you might remember the birther
movement which claimed that barack obama
was not
actually eligible to be president
because of some combination of he was
born in kenya
or he was indonesian or his dad was an
american
or he once ate dog meat in indonesia you
know like whatever the explanation was
it was a ridiculous idea barack obama
was born in hawaii
but it was a hugely racially tinged
movement which actually donald trump was
at the front
and center of uh trump was one of the
loudest and most
prominent birthers for a period of
months if not more than a year talking
about barack obama's birth certificate
and the entire thing
now within mere hours of kamala harris
becoming joe biden's running mate
the birthers are instantly back it's
almost like
if you're not white they question
whether you're really an american that
seems to be the underlying theme here
subtly
subtly being put forward now i on the
one hand i don't want to give this too
much oxygen
but i do want to lay it out generally
for you a guy named john eastman tweeted
quote
is kamala harris eligible for the office
of vice president
here's my article published by newsweek
exploring the issues
short answer it depends now
why newsweek even publish this at all is
a good question
eastman teaches law at chapman
university
and is a fellow at the claremont
institute if you research the claremont
institute you'll find that they're a
right-wing think tank
that was supportive very early of donald
trump and has stuck to trump and
trumpism
uh like i don't know super glue whatever
metaphor you want to use
now of course kamala harris was born in
oakland california
what possible argument would there be
that she's not
eligible to be the president or vice
president now remember
in order to be vice president you have
to be constitutionally eligible
to be president so that's why it's
relevant the argument is
i i hope you're ready for this harris's
dad is jamaican
and was not an american citizen when
kamala harris was born
in i believe it's 1964. kamala harris's
mom
is from india and she was not
a u.s citizen at the time that kamala
harris was born
in oakland california thus kamala
is not a natural-born citizen and thus
could not be
vice president because she is ineligible
to be president of the united states
now in the article eastman goes really
into the weeds with arguments about the
14th amendment and the definition again
i mean it's like barack obama number two
the arguments about what does it mean to
be natural born it's obama birtherism
redux and and by the way they are only
pushing it further by saying this
isn't only the law today
it's about what the founders meant when
they
established how citizenship is conferred
and we can't just look at court
decisions today
although they have some court decisions
they claim
suggest kamala is not eligible it's also
about interpreting the
desires of what the founders meant
hundreds of years ago now there is a lot
more to this
there is actually a real law
conversation that could be had
but in practice it's only being applied
to barack obama and now to kamala harris
in practice this is the same racist
birtherism that we saw with barack obama
and
my instinct is and i hope that this is
the case i don't think it's going to get
a lot of pickup
and part of the reason why isn't going
to be because it's completely baseless
factually
which it is completely baseless
factually with obama it was about the
president
with kamala harris it's about the vp and
i think that may keep it
from getting the attention it it
otherwise might and of course
you know no one said this about john
mccain born in panama they're just fine
accepting well it was a military base
and thus it's fine
uh nobody said this about ted cruz when
he was a candidate for the republican
nomination in 2016 even though he was
born in canada
as you may or may not know current
british prime minister boris johnson
was an american citizen because he was
born i believe it was in manhattan
uh although he has since renounced that
that's no problem but
is kamala harris born in oakland
eligible to be vice president all of a
sudden now
uh they have questions it's the same dog
whistle stuff and it's
almost it's too predictable it's
too on the nose that this is the
direction immediately you have some
pro-trump think-tank legal scholar
uh talking about let's sort of hope that
this is it but i did want to let you
know that it was going on
the trump campaign has now gone full
mask
off and has resorted to tweeting mug
shots of black people
that that's the argument that i punched
my mic there that's the argument
for not voting for joe biden tweeting
mug shots of black people charged with
crimes
these are posts from the verified
twitter account
trump war room trump war room is an
official account
run by the trump 2020 campaign team
and they have been tweeting images like
this one that we're putting up on the
screen for our video audience
of a black man charged with violent
crimes remember in our system you are
innocent until proven guilty
they're very quick to talk about that
when it comes to sexual assault
allegations against people like donald
trump
but again they're highlighting charges
against someone
another example that they tweeted out of
a guy named donovan boone
also black charged with crimes and
there's a ton of these that they've been
tweeting out claiming that
these are people that are free thanks to
biden campaign officials who
donated to pay bail fees
so this is both number one
completely obvious and transparent
in terms of it's just a racist attack to
try to hurt joe biden
and number two and this is the part that
i hate to admit
but really it's an indictment of of of
the people who vote
uh this actually might work i mean i
don't know you know the
the trump war room twitter account is
not necessarily
the place people are going to for news
about the campaign
but the idea that they're floating this
on twitter could lead to
trump talking about it in more detail
and and these are effectively willie
horton ads willie horton ads are still
studied and discussed today if you don't
know what they are
back in 1988 um massachusetts governor
michael dukakis who
has been a guest on this program
multiple times um
was the democratic nominee and was
running against george h.w bush
and george h.w bush started publicizing
with a variety of different so-called
willie horton ads how
michael dukakis let willie horton out
and it was the start of this idea of
democrats
it was more officially codifying the
idea of democrats are going to release
dangerous black people into society
you aren't safe vote for the republican
who will actually keep you safe
this is the exact same thing that we are
seeing from the trump campaign and when
you step back and you know they're
tweeting mug shots of black people i
mean
it's just it's fully brazen at this
point in time trump's continued use of
the term china virus he's talked about
you know kung flu wuhan flew
all of this stuff back at the beginning
of his campaign
uh mexico is not sending its bests it's
sending rapists and criminals and some
who i'm sure are probably good people or
whatever the exact quote was
playing coy with the white supremacists
who have been
activated and coalesced by his campaign
we've seen it all
time and time again and this is
essentially the same stuff so the the
real practical question for biden harris
is how to deal with this there i sort of
exchanged a few messages with democratic
strategists
about if you were running the biden
campaign how do you deal with this
because on the one hand you could say
well
it might actually be effective to
uh try to expose and criticize the fact
that the trump campaign official
campaign people are
using these uh sort of racially tinged
willy horton type strategies
um but on the other hand it doesn't
really seem to have worked then what i
mean by that is
trump has been saying xenophobic stuff
and uh
using racist dog whistles for years he
did it in 2015 early
in his campaign into 2016. he's done it
throughout his presidency
and his approval rating stuck right
around the low 40s
and what has actually hurt donald trump
over the last several months
have been three issues it's been
coronavirus handling it's been the
economic situation as a result of the
coronavirus handling
and trump's authoritarian reaction to
the george floyd protest suggesting and
actually sending in
national guard and sort of uh further
militarizing reactions to protests that
are over police brutality to begin with
so
the you know grab them by the
you-know-what stuff
the um going after trump for the
xenophobia
it really hasn't worked so other
democratic strategists i
i spoke to said i would ignore it i
would focus
on what has actually hurt donald trump
and in the event
two days ago that biden and harris did
kamala harris focused on
an unnecessarily bad economic situation
coronavirus hit every country and every
country's economy has suffered
but it's worse here because of trump's
failed response we know that that
actually is
mattering to voters uh hit trump on
coronavirus
which harris did during this first
campaign event 48 hours ago
that's another approach from democratic
strategists who are saying the going
after trump for his
crass nature and the language and all
that it's not really worked
focus on what has worked i don't know
what the biden harris team is going to
do
about the birtherism about the willy
horton ads and all of this stuff
but we will follow it and we will see on
august 23rd
we will be at the 15-year anniversary of
the show
huge milestone for us on the one hand
we're heading towards
a million subscribers on youtube and on
the other hand we have this amazing
milestone that is going on so on
august 23rd we will be sending out an
email to everybody on our mailing list
with a ungodly is really the best way i
could describe it
membership discount i would love for you
to take part i would love for you to
grab a membership
as we get into this final stretch uh
before the election
and in order to be notified on august
23rd just get on
on my mailing list by signing up at
davidpakman.com
we'll take a quick break we will open up
the phone lines i have some of your
questions i want to answer a little bit
later
we've got a great bonus show it's friday
and we have a fantastic program for you
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy
science they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about 8 bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
today's new members of the day are jack
typala
and janet revez thanks to jack and janet
for signing up very much
appreciate your support and also a big
thank you to today's long time
sustaining member of the day that's
katherine williamson catherine if you
can believe this has been a member
of for just under five years and
deserves
extra extra praise very very important
stuff
you can grab a membership at
joinpakman.com of course the
normal prices i find eminently
reasonable
but if you want to take a 40 discount
just use the coupon code
2020 now and you will save actually no
that's 66 percent off forget about 40
off 2020 now will save you 66
let's go to the phone lines at 617
830
we will start with our caller from the
2-0-1
area code and it might take just a
moment to make sure
uh that the caller can hear me
and that i can hear the caller caller
from 201 can you hear me you are on
right now
yeah hi can you hear me i can how are
you who's this
hi um i'm joshua i'm from new jersey
great what's on your mind today
yeah so my question um it's uh it's
about
the pandemic that's going on yes
yeah so um obviously the queen of ours
deaths have recently surpassed 160 000
which if you do the math is more than 50
911s
yes and obviously besides the death the
pandemic has cost
people's jobs and their houses and so
much more yeah despite all of that
republicans and their voters have
remained uh firmly
ignorant of the severity of this
pandemic so with all of that in mind
my question is um just how much worse do
you think this pandemic has to get for
republicans and their voters to finally
realize the sheer gravity of the
situation
and thereby commit to substantial action
i i i believe you know shockingly mask
wearing at the individual level to
maybe even republicans like passing
actual release bills
i believe that uh it will not get
that bad enough for them
uh while donald trump is still president
if he loses in november and so what what
i mean by that is
if biden wins in november it will still
not be bad enough
at that point for republicans to say you
know our approach was not the right one
when you look at
just about every other country with some
few exceptions i just don't think it
will get that bad because it's a
combination of ignorance denial
this feeling of inevitability that like
listen this it is what it is we just we
can't stop our lives when of course as
you're pointing out a lot of those
hundred and almost 170
000 deaths now those many of those were
optional and they came from not taking
the right measures i i don't think we're
going to get there
i think that it's going to time out now
if biden doesn't win
and trump gets another four years i
think that
he's going to be saved by the bell
anyway because before republicans say
it's now bad enough that we need to do
more we'll have a vaccine
so so i think that they it will not get
to the point where republicans say whoa
we got it wrong we've got to do a
rethink
yeah yeah oh yeah i definitely agree i
was on the
uh pessimistic side myself that
republicans would just commit to their
ignorance
yeah and yeah i mean it's just so
frustrating because well
um ethnically i'm from south korea and i
watch
uh the korean news every night and it's
we're an absolute embarrassment yeah the
united states like
um on like the south korean uh news
outlets
like they they bring up entire segments
where they basically just
roast the united states for 30 minutes
plus
like they'll bring up clips of like the
adults having temper tantrums about
wearing masks they'll
bring up like clips of trump saying to
slow down testing
yeah we're an absolute embarrassment
it's so frustrating that
not only is the man in the white house
like
denying the significance of this problem
but everyone
around him is also committing to
ignorance yeah when i said that the u.s
is a laughingstock it was not a
a metaphor it was i mean literally the
world is
in shock at how poorly we are dealing
with this and you know the problem
with with all of it is the people who
most need to hear it don't care that
south korea
and france france and the netherlands
that they're all laughing at us because
they they're like
we we do what we do we don't care about
you know [ __ ] europeans or people in
asia halfway across
they just don't care so it's like
there's no reaching them sadly but it is
what it is and hopefully we can remove
trump sooner than later
yeah definitely yeah it's just so
frustrating
all right thanks david thank you i
appreciate the phone call great to hear
from you
uh let's go next to our caller
from the 832 area code who's calling
today from 832
uh hi my name's drew can you hear me
yeah drew what's going on
oh that's not much um basically my
question is more regarding
the potential victory that we may or as
democrats we might actually have
do you think that uh if we end up
winning in 2020
like collectively i'm talking the senate
the house and the presidency
do you think we can pull the same stuff
that dick cheney pulled in 2010
and basically redistricts so that we
have more control over the legislature
and basically reverse uh
redistricting if you will okay yeah so
very important so you're
you're pointing out not only do
democrats have the opportunity to take
the white house take the senate and
maintain or extend control in the house
we also are in a sense this year
the 2020 census and in 2021
that census will be used
for a whole bunch of different things
including redistricting figuring out
distribution of funds the answer is yes
and you know this is the there's a
there's a discussion that sometimes
happens about
should the left just go low in order to
keep
up with the right and very often i
believe the answer is no
in the sense that if we need to do the
immoral things they do to win
we're not really better we're just
saying
hey we're all willing to do the same
stuff because we think we're right that
makes us just as bad as them and so with
a lot of these things i'm not for that
when it comes to the census um
if democrats have the opportunity in
2021
to do all of the things that republicans
did
after the 2010 census then they there's
actually a moral imperative
to do it because this is not about
changing the system right now this is
how it works and
the opportunity comes every 10 years and
very often democrats have not
been in power uh and i believe that when
it comes to redistricting and
distribution of funds on the basis of
the senses yes if we especially if we
hold
the white house uh if we take the white
house hold the house and take the senate
it is the opportunity it must be done
and
we've got to do it and not look back
i see that's i i like you taking the
high ground but i've got to be honest
i'm tired of taking the high ground when
it comes to republicans but
i i appreciate you having a little bit
more
uh a decent person than i am okay well
i don't know that it's that i mean i
think forever it's interesting that you
say say it that way because
i think just everybody has a different
bar you know some people would steal to
feed their family
and some people would kill one person
and some
people might commit genocide to feed
their family and it's not about
good versus bad necessarily in such
moralistic terms but i
you know i i just i do think that um
uh it's it's sometimes a difference of
circumstance as well
and uh there's there's no necessarily
right or wrong answer but i i appreciate
the topic being brought up it is it is
an important one
all right thank you very much okay thank
you appreciate the phone call
let's see who else we've got holding
let's try our caller from the 845 area
code who's calling today from 845.
i think that's me how you doing david it
is david cadillac
david cadillac i like it all right
yes um i had a question for you
speaking of taking higher ground uh i
got a bit of an anger
problem most of my life and i got it
under control
but nowadays with all these ignorant
people you know walking around without
wearing their masks and
you know the regular moronic things we
see as normal people
i feel myself coming back to the person
i used to be in trying to avoid it
because i'm so angry at these idiots
i don't know what to do about it and
speaking of taking the higher ground
i really appreciated your interview with
that um jessie lee peterson guy
that made my day it was so entertaining
that i just wanted to call and say
thanks for uh
living everything up a little bit i
needed it well i
i appreciate that now are you so where i
don't know if i hear like a new yorker
maybe a philly accent there where are
you located that you're dealing with
these these morons so often
the town i'm in is actually chester new
york okay i worked in manhattan all my
life so i'm only
a half hour away okay we've seen the
devastation here
so when you're saying you're getting mad
at people
is it are you getting in verbal
confrontations is it escalating to
physical
well it hasn't gotten physical yet but
uh they
are i used to be the person who would
agitate the fight
nowadays it seems like they have someone
nicely and
they want to agitate a fight so you know
i've done the right thing i learned my
life lessons i walk away but at the same
time
i don't know how people deal with these
but i just don't know it's not easy to
ignore anything
but what is it sort of like you ask
someone to put a mask on and they lose
their mind or what's going on lose
their minds like literally like crazy
people
i compare them to children really
because they lose you know toddler fits
is what it seems like
but they lose their minds police too i
got a confrontation with a cop last week
because he was in the store getting his
coffee next to me i said hey buddy
you think he might want to put a mask on
we're in a gas station
and he lost his mind i had to leave
because i thought he would just leave
and arrest me or something else
really so police saw what town was that
that police officers aren't wearing
masks indoors i thought the entire state
of new york
had had a pretty clear mandate on that
i know we say it all the time but
there's in line that you can report
people here in new york
and uh you know it doesn't do a lot of
good but
at least it's a step listen here's what
i would say because i understand i hear
the frustration and i would understand
it
the way i might try to resist the
escalations would be you know what
this is such a bigger problem than this
one guy or gal
that even if i go completely crazy and
change
their mind it's not actually i can't
possibly do that with everybody and so i
it's it's a sad realization but i would
take a more resigned view
that really this the change in people's
attitudes needs to be systemic
and that you can't shout everybody into
submission and i would approach it that
way to try to not get too uh
you know hot behind the ears so to speak
yeah no that's absolutely dead on you
know we just have to keep trying
to calmly as we all can and hopefully
change some minds
exactly and hopefully before we know it
there will be a vaccine we'll figure it
out
yeah all right my friend thank you i
appreciate the phone call appreciate it
thank you yeah great to hear from you
dave cadillac from chester new york
there
um okay let's go next to
our caller from the 720
area code caller uh where are you what's
your name where are you calling from
uh is that me yeah it is
uh my i'm aaron i'm calling from uh utah
actually
interesting i just had a question
regarding the uh
election coming up you've talked at
length about how you don't think
uh really the election interference is
going to be too bad
and how the how he'll just leave
and no matter if he loses he isn't the
president well hold on a second let me
let me let's
can we pause can we pause just for a
second there hold on i want to make sure
we're not mistaken so
i've not said i don't think the election
interference will be significant what
i've said
is experts who have looked at what trump
is planning
believe that each of his little tactics
will only have a modest impact and it
could flip the election to him but
if we get the turnout up the turnout
will do
far more than any of trump's tactics can
do that so it wasn't it's not so that
it's
it's not going to be significant it's
that we know how to fight it which is by
overwhelming the vote and yes i have
said
i believe if trump loses he will go
eventually it may be under protest but
he will go
right i was more asking like do you
think anything like the
2000s uh florida recount type stuff
could happen again
yes and that sways it sort of even
though we turn out
uh it doesn't work absolutely and this
is why i've said
when we now you know thinking back now
when we look at trump's supreme court
picks
his judgeships the fact that he's now
starting to file lawsuits against vote
by mail
we need to run the score up we need this
to be
like an overwhelming win for joe biden
because the closer it is within states
or the closer it is from the popular
vote standpoint
it could provide cover for judges to do
very very bad things and if the results
are
very lopsided it just makes it more
difficult for
a court as an example to hand
any state any vote anything to donald
trump and that's why i think it's so
important that we have the biggest
possible margin in november we can't
just win by a little bit
we actually need to destroy trump
i agree i just wanted to see what your
opinion is thanks for taking a call
all right appreciate it thank you for
the call let's take a quick break if you
are holding please don't hang up because
after
what is going to feel like just an
incredibly short break
i'm going to go right back to the phone
the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the world
famous
bonus show as well as commercial free
audio and video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
welcome back to the david pakman show
all right let's go back to the phones at
617-830-4750 and see what is on people's
minds a lot going on
uh we will next try our caller from the
713 area code who's calling today from
713 where are you calling from
hello david this is james i'm from
houston texas
what's going on james
uh yeah so to preface this i'm kind of
uh in between
the two third parties i'm kind of the
undecided between the green party
hawkins and the libertarian party and
this pick
like i have very progressive social
views and things like that
as well as economic views but this pick
for kamala harris just
really i was i was kind of on the biden
train but now i'm
i'm really gonna i'm really convinced i
have to vote for hawkins
he's also got a black running mate
angela walker but i just don't think
kamala harris is
the right pick she's she feels like such
a few to the african-american community
as well
okay so um what so so what
can you say more about that what was
what is it exactly your
her record as california attorney
general is what's concerning you that's
why you might not vote for biden harris
yeah i mean i i'm obviously i i don't
like trump
really i don't even like biden that much
but just her record and also
i was kind of on the tulsi i was kind of
a big supporter
supporter of tulsi and the only thing
that brought kamala harris kind of back
into the spotlight
was joe biden kind of defending her and
then
saying that he will uh keep her as a
pick for his vp okay but does that have
anything to do with why you would or
wouldn't vote for
for them
yeah i just i just don't think it's a
of it's not she's she's a she's a
warhawk she's a
drug warrior and i don't think any of
this system that was
made and accelerated in the 90s under
the presidency of bill clinton
really needs to continue anymore and has
she said that it would continue
well i mean i just don't i mean bull
biden doesn't want to legalize marijuana
that's true no he doesn't
i just don't feel that a four four or
12 years of biden and harris i don't i'm
not saying it's going to
be that way but i just don't feel like
stuff is going to change as much
socially on these on these economic
issues as well because
well hold on a second let's back up hold
on but we also because of the war on
truck
i have to stop you there oh if anything
over the last
three weeks the divide on economic
remember
it's biden versus trump right so kamala
harris's economic ideas from
from three years ago are not what is
going to determine
what the next four look like a huge
chasm or chasm has opened up
between biden and trump on economic
policy i mean trump wants to
cut the payroll tax which funds social
security
whereas biden wants to uncap it above
four hundred thousand dollars
that that's like 99 to 1 difference
uh on capital gains trump wants to cut
capital gains
biden wants to tax capital gains as
ordinary income
i mean i could go on but on economic
policy
you know whatever your views are on
harris we there is
nothing similar about biden and trump on
that issue at this point and to say
there is is very deceptive
oh i totally support biden on the
economic issues it's just the social
issues
okay well i mean let me ask you this
let's just bottom line bottom line
do you prefer biden or trump to be
president if it's going to be one of the
two because it is going to be one of the
two who do you prefer
oh definitely biden okay so then maybe
vote for biden
yeah i mean i'll still i'll still do a
little bit of research but thanks for
thanks for answering my call david okay
thank you i appreciate it thank you very
much
uh let's see what else we've got here
let's go to
our caller from the 937
area code caller from 937 what's your
name where are you calling from
uh is this me yes it is
oh my gosh that's awesome uh hi my name
is austin
i'm from uh flavortown ohio all right
and austin please just keep the phone a
little further from your mouth because
you're coming in a little hot and it's
crunching
all right sorry is that better oh my god
that's so much better thank you
okay uh so my question
is um that
so i'm kind of i've been talking with my
friends a lot about this and i just
wanted to get your opinion on it
um i am really
concerned about all this malpractice
that's going to be happening with
the postal service yes and i'm worried
about
voting and uh voting in by mail
so i feel like i have to vote in person
but i also am concerned about you know
voting in person because of coronavirus
of
well obvious reasons yeah right
so i guess like
where should my priorities lie well okay
so
he basically this is going to be a call
that a lot of people have to make there
are many people who rightly would
would as i've said crawl over broken
glass to vote in november
so you are going to have to make the
call can you get
as i've said before they can slow down
the mail
but right now it doesn't seem like
they're just gonna throw
absentee ballots in the trash so if you
can get your ballot
several weeks before the election and
mail it in even if they delay
the ballots three four five days it's
going to get there and by all
reasonable estimates it's going to be
counted so that's number one right the
the they're they're going to try but if
you can get your absentee ballot in and
send it in early as i'm going to be
doing here in massachusetts you really
shouldn't have a problem
when it comes to voting in person listen
the situations are dramatically
different in different precincts where
some places you you put a mask on and
you go in and you're in and out in 10
minutes and it's no big deal
in other places you could be waiting for
hours surrounded by people mostly not
wearing masks and that's a real
concern and you it's going to be a very
individual decision
unfortunately there's no there's no way
i can tell you what makes sense but i
i am confident that you should be able
to vote and have your vote counted i'm
relatively certain that you will be able
to achieve that
that makes sense yeah
uh yeah thanks david all right thank you
yes a concern that many people have and
is going to be a very big deal going
forward let's go to our caller from the
281 area code who's calling today from
281
his emmy yes it is
hey david um longtime fan uh you're
actually the first person that got me
into podcasting so i just wanted to say
thank you
thank you love it um i had a question in
regards to
um the piece you had yesterday in
regards to
being a hobbyist um i was curious on
your thoughts on how to
i guess make the change from a hobbyist
into sort of a
of an activist um because it is very
hard to get
out of the mindset of just simply
looking at the
news or information that may suit you
and
applying that to actual change outside
of that
bubble that a person may put themselves
in well number one just asking the
question is important because a lot of
people who consume
political news as entertainment never
ask this question they never realize
that just like watching
msnbc doesn't really involve you
in politics and so i think there's a
couple different things number one
is i recommend everybody at the macro
level
don't just consume news and in fact i
have a very
specific and limited uh consumption of
the day-to-day news obviously i'm
producing a show and i'm reacting to
what's happening so
in in doing so i consume
information about what's going on but i
actually am focusing more and more of my
time on understanding history and
economics and political philosophy etc
so one
recommendation i always make is if you
want to take
the news and get more involved in making
change
learn about other things that will
better allow you to interpret what's
going on and contextualize it in history
and within the context of different
political systems etc
but then beyond that um oftentimes what
allows people to go from being
political hobbyists to activists is
you can't be an activist on every issue
and so
figure out what's most important to you
and try to
activate there so if it's climate and
local schools as an example
figure out how you can get involved in
wherever you live expanding uh
the infrastructure for transitioning to
clean energy as an example or you know
i'm just kind of riffing here but the
the idea being you can't just say well
i'm a progressive activist and i'm going
to get involved everything i pay
attention to i'm now going to get
involved and it's just not possible
there's too many things in the world so
figure out what's most important to you
and then kind of work backwards and say
okay where can i most most effectively
and ac acutely affect some change in
these particular
areas i think that that's really the
best start
got it so more narrow focusing and not
being so
broad we're thinking because i think
that's what comes overwhelming at times
yeah a lot of people care about so many
different things that it
just becomes a too much at once focus on
your sphere of influence right
what can i impact what can i get
involved in right now and start there
you can still pay attention to
everything else that's going on
but try to narrow your focus of activism
right i mean i think right now i'm in
houston texas and um
right now what's what's outstanding is
what you've also talked about how the
ever since the the data change from the
cdc to
the trump administration it has not been
at all what the numbers have looked like
here yes and he's been
specifically i think which has passed a
large amount of cases so
it's very concerning i think that's one
of the main points of activism that i'm
aiming for is really
trying to be have be more self-aware and
spread the actual truth with
what i can within my own abilities all
right
very good it sounds like you're well on
your way i appreciate the phone call and
please do check back in and let us know
uh
how things ended up going where you
ended up focusing
let's go to our caller from the 419
area code who's calling today from 419
hello david is this me yes it is
uh hello i've called him before i am
from rural ohio
and so my question today is how do you
argue
for a tap for no tax cuts for the rich
with republicans because i've tried this
in the past
and it hasn't worked so their argument
in the past has been
well you see if you tax them then the
businesses are going to go away
and they made all that money legally
they did it
because they just worked harder than
everybody else which isn't true
so i tried arguing with them about it
saying how
these tax tax cuts if you tax them you
could put it towards infrastructure
medicare and overall improving the
quality of life for your country
and they just straight up refuses so my
question for you is how do you argue
well one of the things you have to do is
you have to really
separate the arguments because even
right there you gave me
two different arguments and you kind of
blended them together and you said
i'm having a hard time arguing against
this the first one was
that if you tax you're going to
hurt the businesses or take they'll stop
doing it they'll stop working or
sometimes it extends to they'll move to
another country or whatever the case may
be you'll disincentivize work or
whatever that's one argument
then you went on to trying to justify
the reason we have taxes as necessary to
pay for things and to have
roads and public schools and whatever
else so
one really important it's impossible to
go through every counterpoint point and
counterpoint here with you
but one thing you really want to do is
you want to separate
out the different arguments and make
them really justify it so
to pick one there's this idea that if
the tax goes too high
they'll just stop their business it's a
disincentive to keep
working because too much of their money
will be going to taxes okay we can we
can deal with that there's a lot of
scholarship on that
and um we can start to talk about
well the devil is in the details what
should the top marginal tax rate be what
we have generally found
is that the the tax the top marginal tax
rate
at which the government maximizes
revenue is around 70 percent now that
doesn't mean
you get taxed 70 on all your income that
might mean like
once you get to 10 million a year in
income you start paying
70 or something like that and all of the
scholarship
on it suggests that that does not create
a disincentive
to work and that the truth is if it
started to create one at that point
maybe it wouldn't be altogether a bad
thing so
that's just an example of how you've got
to separate these arguments and not
allow
what gets difficult is you'll have three
or four different arguments that are
sort of related but not really thrown at
you and then you're in the position of
having to pick them apart and respond to
each of them all
all together don't allow that take
control of the narrative and go
point by point and obviously it takes
time to do it so you've got to have some
patience
yeah because i feel like the main
problem with trying to argue this
with republicans like my friends for
example is i mean they respect my
opinion they they listen to me
it's just their parents have grown them
up in a way
that they already have their hard set
beliefs
yes and nothing will change their mind
right i've just learned to accept this
fact
yep so what you have to do in those
cases
is recognizing that is important you're
not going to change their minds by
beating them over the head
get them to justify their beliefs deeply
with a sort of socratic method of
questioning and one place on taxes you
can start is okay listen
do you want to get get the crazies out
of the conversation by saying
are our taxes legal and should we have
some taxes okay that's the first place
if someone says taxes are theft or
slavery
and are illegal or the tax rate should
be zero
i wouldn't even waste my time with those
people that's not
it's just it's go do something else go
read a book you're gonna have some some
better thing you can focus on once they
concede
okay yeah midway through my argument
i realized this and i tried changing the
topic
to something else i forgot what it was
yeah they started
they started coming after me saying how
i'm i'm against
billionaires and how just because they
work so much harder
than i do that i shouldn't be jealous of
them which i'm not jealous
they made their money through illegal
ways
money laundering such like the trump
campaign 170 dollars
of money laundering oh you know what i'm
so uh now i'm starting to see why maybe
these conversations aren't going so well
i'm you're you're sort of all over the
place because now you're on to
talking about individual billionaires
who are accused of
but that's a very different conversation
from taxation and what the tax rate
would be so what i
what i would really do is don't don't go
all over the place with arguments about
money laundering and should billion
you you've really got to narrow the
conversation find
two or three really good arguments and
come prepared because i can
i can see you're probably getting
flustered and going all over the place
i didn't i didn't bring that up okay i
was still staying on the main taxes how
you know taxes pay for everything you
need taxes like
in life there's two certain things death
and taxes well but they would argue that
the taxes shouldn't be certain so
this is where i would start i i would
start
i would start with an example i gave you
our taxes okay it sounds like i'm
i may be on speaker and we're starting
to echo you've got a lot going on there
and a lot to contend with but i would
really
first focus in on do they concede that
we need
some taxes and that taxes are legal and
then you can work from there in the gray
area
and narrow the focus on to what what the
tax rates should be
all right my friend i appreciate the
phone call sounds like you've got a real
that's a real matzo ball hanging out
there in terms of some of these uh some
of these arguments you're in
uh and i very much wish you the best all
right that does it for me today as far
as phone calls are concerned i will take
more calls again
in the future not today not today but in
the future
and i as always i feel terribly that i
wasn't able to get to everybody who
called in
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about them
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
all right let's get into audience
questions for the week
very important relevant questions that
tie together
a lot of the different issues that we've
been discussing first one is hey david
if the third quarter numbers really are
as good as donald trump predicts
uh could that rocket trump to
re-election
on november 3rd so understand the timing
uh
first quarter is january february march
the first quarter numbers came out on
april 30th
as an estimate and then they were more
fine-tuned on may
30th the second quarter april may june
we got estimated second quarter numbers
on july
30th and then we will get presumably
more accurate and precise numbers
on august 30th so that means that for
the third quarter
july august september we will get
estimates of gdp on october
30th that is four days before the
presidential election
so i would not just
be thinking it's possible i would be
thinking
it's almost a guarantee that on
october 30th there will be good
gdp numbers why why will they be good
well
when the gdp goes down more than 30
percent
you have a new significantly lower
baseline
a record low baseline meaning any
increase is going to seem relatively
larger
now bear in mind think about the number
100
if you start at 100 and you lose 30
percent you're down at 70.
if you then gain 20 you go back
up to 84. okay down 30
up 20 you start at 100 you go down to 70
you go back up to 84. you will hear
trump claim on october 30th this is the
biggest
rise in gdp in american history and it
will be true
on a percentage basis because of that
new lower
base of 70 so to speak
but we will still be at 84. we will
still be
imagining it's 20 percent up we will
still be down
16 from where we were before the second
quarter so
will the economy really be doing great
when we get that announcement no will
donald trump
try to take credit for it of course
and will donald trump claim that it is
the best gdp result we have ever had
yes now i am worried about this i
i genuinely am worried about it why
because there's a lot of
really um ignorant
people there's a lot of easily
manipulable or manipulatable i don't
know if either or both are words
uh people and there are also people who
really don't want to vote for joe biden
and they will look for
any excuse not to do it and so
inevitably we need to plan for it on
october 30th we will have
96 hours before the election
during which we will need to fight the
talking point
that no one has ever overseen a bigger
gdp
increase in a single quarter than donald
trump and it will be true
but of course it will not be reflective
of the broader
economic situation and that is uh
really what we what we all need to
remember and listen this gets me back to
poll says biden's up nine margin of
error
is 3.5 that means it's possible biden's
really only winning
by two if trump swings just
one percent of the population on october
30th by
saying look at this great gdp victory uh
that might mean biden wins the popular
vote by one and you can as we know from
2016 you can win the popular vote
and still lose the electoral college
we've seen that with hillary clinton we
saw it with
al gore in the year 2000 we've actually
seen it several times
so we need to be very very vigilant
there's going to be we need to plan for
it okay
and in fact this is where democrats are
just terrible
we know this is going to happen on
october 30th
trump will claim that he is fixed
everything
and brought us the biggest that cannot
be you all know you know economic
prosperity all that stuff
what do we do for those 96 hours to
ensure
to ensure that it doesn't work to swing
the election
in his favor i don't know what the
answer is but it's going to happen
and we damn damn well better have a plan
uh hey david at what point would a
military
coup to remove trump not be the absolute
worst
option i'm really only half joking so
i think we have to be very careful about
these questions
um donald tru i get why people are
sort of worried and tense about this
donald trump has floated the idea of
delaying the election he's talked about
it's going to be rigged he almost
certainly will claim some aspect of it
is rigged
he still hasn't even accepted the
popular vote results of 2016 which is an
election he won
you can be sure that he is going to find
something to take issue with
in november and certainly if he loses he
absolutely is going to
i don't think it's going to come to
anything like a military coup
i i most people in the audience seem to
be on board with me
and on the same page that january 20th
trump if he loses or there is no
election
he is no longer the president and
it's on the one hand not going to
require
a military coup to remove donald trump
but on the other hand i think that he's
going to go
uh i think he he you know sam cedar
earlier this week talked about lawsuits
and lawsuits may be going all the way up
to the supreme
court i don't think that that's totally
implausible and that's certainly a
reason for us to try to run up the score
and have a huge popular vote victory
first step is not to lose in the popular
vote next step is to have a big
popular vote victory which hopefully
will translate into an electoral college
victory
uh but we know the tricks that they're
planning
uh there's foreign meddling going on
again
postmaster is trying to kneecap and
[ __ ] the post office they're trying
to prevent mail-in vote voting
and they're suing states in order to try
to do it
they're deregistering voters they're
trying to close polling places
we we know all the tactics the experts
have looked at it and here's the
the bottom line all of these things can
certainly have an effect on the results
if everybody goes out and votes
we overwhelm it all of these techniques
only work when half the country doesn't
vote
if we actually get the vote out these
questions of the military removing trump
or whatever
they instantly become moot they really
do so
i think that what i would encourage the
audience to do
is trust that the best
remedy is for all of us to vote
all of these probably you know will
trump leave or not
will we need the military to remove him
an overwhelming defeat of donald trump
in both
the popular and electoral votes is going
to prevent
all of these issues if it's overwhelming
even this supreme court with two of
donald trump's elections neil gorsuch
and brett kavanaugh
is not going to do anything that that
would somehow allow trump to stay in
power
the best remedy is every single person
voting
hey david will republicans support an
election day
an election delay rather if donald trump
is definitely going to lose so this is
an interesting question
because it first assumes
that republicans or trumpists might come
to the conclusion that trump definitely
is going to lose
i don't think the average trumpist is
going to believe that going into
november in other words
the average trumpist no matter what if
trump says he's doing well in the polls
which he's been saying even though he's
not
they will believe trump has a chance so
in practice
i don't think this scenario is going to
come up because you're not going to
convince
the the vast majority of trumpists that
trump is
is going to lose let's imagine you did
would they then support an election
delay if trump wanted it
absolutely if there's one thing we've
learned during this presidency
it's that anything trump wants
his followers want if it's the
authoritarian deployment
of paramilitaries with no badges and
unmarked vans to portland and chicago
and wherever
uh even if they thought they were small
government conservative libertarians or
whatever up until
they're supporting it no question about
it uh when it's
trump against vote by mail they're
against vote by mail trump comes out as
he did
last week or the week before and says in
florida
it's safe and everybody should vote by
mail they immediately fall in line and
they say yes yes everybody should be
voting by mail because donald trump said
so so
if donald trump were trump has floated
it
he's not said we need to delay but he's
floated it and he said we might not know
the results for weeks or years he even
said which is
absolutely ridiculous if trump actually
came out and said
i believe we should delay the election
to whatever date it would be crazy right
there'd be no legal basis for it
of course a huge portion of his
followers will fall in line
because they fall in line with
absolutely anything that he says
we have to make sure that we start
voting now
i mean there are states where in i think
is it two and a half weeks or
three weeks um early voting absentee
ballots
start we have to overwhelm the vote
so that it's not close and we need to
just remember
that a federal election has never been
delayed there have never been delays to
presidential elections
his followers are liable to support
absolutely anything that he wants
what we have to make sure we do is to
vote participate keep the pressure on as
far as the post office keep the pressure
on as far as
uh vote by mail and um none of this
stuff is really going to become an issue
and i'm
i'm not i understand why i'm getting so
many questions like
will republicans support delaying the
election or will the military be
required to remove donald trump i get it
i understand why that's going on and
it's because many of you
are willing to crawl over broken glass
to vote in november
one way or the other by mail or in
person because you see the importance of
removing donald trump i get it
i do not believe it's actually going to
come to that i do not believe we are
going to have
any serious possibility of an election
delay
i do not believe that if donald trump
loses the military will be required to
remove him i do not believe it
these could be famous last words i will
eat my hat
uh if it ends up working out that way in
november
into january we have a great bonus show
for you today
get instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a member
at joinpakman.com or a patron
at patreon.com davidpakmanshow
i will see you on the bonus show
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blinkist the app that
lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
for free
and save 25 percent off of a
subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video